would you let your girl have like a like
big buff like trainer
she she goes to him she goes to him
three times a week but it's at his house
bro the trainer is the first dude who's
gonna bang your i know i know no you
don't understand my thought process i
mean 100 percent you don't understand my
thought process on there you wanted to
get banked no i don't you don't
understand dude if you wanted something
i don't need to say all the stuff and
you didn't mean to it's okay i don't
find it this is why yeah no it's fine i
did say basically
dude but it's
fine go ahead man i'm just you would
like to ask him brendan it's not going
to happen
four times a week and this dude just a
dime how about asking your [ __ ] coins
do this do it seven times a week oh
i hope so dude i bet it doesn't happen
and if it does
we deal with it
damn man we deal with it confidence we
deal with it dude i've got so much other
[ __ ] going on in my brain
i'll deal with it you understand oh wow
you you do it but she's not gonna crack
if she does
your boy's still alive and we'll deal
with it wow and i need it and i need it
there you go trainers hit him up in the
dms hit my girl up in the d let's see
this shit's gotta go though this morning
i'm gonna be the trainer with your girl
there's your girl
yeah
there you go
i like to hear if a guy hit on her i
like to hear look come on let me know
let me know dude let me know where were
you the [ __ ] market some guy said
something yeah let me know dude yeah
yeah why do you sell like smell like
black pickle
what market were you at huh
let's go
brought it full circle and put on the
whole team legendary trio grinning chris
and theo what you mean you know it's the
king and the sting and the wing
[Music]